what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and we
have some new spider-man footage to go
over today and really really important
dialogue from this new footage in fact
this new dialogue could prove that
marvel studios and sony are really
altering their trailer footage from what
the movie could actually be marvel
studios is known for doing this and it
would make sense that they would do it
for spider-man no way home even though
it is sony they're still being extremely
secretive about this movie we still
haven't heard anything about toby
maguire spider-man or andrew garfield
spider-man even though they have showed
us all of the villains from the other
universes and in this video i'll talk
about just how hard marvel studios and
sony are trying to keep toby and andrew
a secret until people actually see the
film so a lot to talk about today but
first big congratulations to mr knight
son for being the winner of our
spider-man collectible giveaway he's
already been contacted but i'm going to
be doing a massive giveaway and i'm
going to announce this about mid next
week there is going to be a ton of
opportunities to win a lot of really
cool stuff so be sure to subscribe and
hit the bell so you don't miss out on
that announcement now we actually have
two new trailer tv spots to break down
both with some new footage but it's
really the dialogue that i want to talk
about because i think the dialogue
actually reveals a lot and let's talk
about this first one that has new
dialogue from jamie foxx
what's happening
visitors from every universe over here
my old friend spiderman
multiverse is real
of course i think most people would spot
out what the big thing here is is that
elektra says my old friend spider-man
and this happens right after dr strange
says visitors from every universe are
here and as i hear dr strange say this
more and more in each tv spot and
trailer that we get i definitely don't
think he's talking about every single
universe i actually think he's talking
about every spider-man universe and only
dealing with actually a few universes
because we know these villains come from
actually just two other universes toby
maguire's universe and andrew garfield's
universe but the main dialogue here is
what elektro says my old friend
spider-man now right off the bat you
wonder who exactly he's talking to and
of course there are only two options one
is he is actually talking to andrew
garfield spider-man of course who he
went up against in amazing spider-man 2.
now if he saw andrew garfield without
the mask on he would obviously recognize
who he is in fact we know that this is
confirmed to be true because in the
trailer where dog ox sees our spider-man
without his mask on and realizes that
it's tom holland spider-man and not toby
maguire spider-man he says you're not
peter so it's been established that
these villains from other universes when
they get into our universe the main mcu
timeline they do see a clear difference
in the spider-man that they see without
the mask on at least but if they see him
with the mask on they can still tell
that there's a slight difference but
don't necessarily think that it's a
different spider-man this is also
demonstrated where doc ock says in a
trailer and tv spots your fancy new suit
isn't going to help you doc ock
recognizes that it's not the same
spider-man suit that he thought toby was
wearing his first initial thought was
that it wasn't a different spider-man
but it was toby wearing a different suit
but the main point being he could tell a
difference so again we have two choices
jamie foxx's electro is talking to
andrew garfield spider-man or he is
talking to of course tom holland
spider-man and it is very possible that
we could get a scene with electro and
tom holland spider-man that is very
similar to the one that we get with doc
ock jamie foxx's electro see spider-man
he thinks it's andrew garfield
spider-man seeks out revenge and goes to
fight him and then of course he would
realize that it's actually not the same
spider-man but here's the deal we do
know that andrew garfield will be in the
film and we do know there is going to be
a rematch between electro and andrew
garfield spider-man so this could
literally be dialogue from that rematch
it could be from right before these two
go into battle against one another and
if it is that's pretty dang cool now we
do have another tv spot and i'm actually
very very curious about the dialogue on
this one and i think you will be too
check this out
spider-man is in fact peter parker
my entire life got screwed up
could you make it so that mysterio never
revealed my identity you ready
what just happened
when i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors looks like we got
competition
from every universe
i promise i'll fix this
exclusively at movie theaters december
17th rated pg-13 so to me this tv spot
shows something to me that is very clear
here that isn't so clear in the other
trailers in the official teaser in the
main trailer dr strange says the whole
world is about to forget that peter
parker is spider-man but in this tv spot
it seems very clear what peter is asking
strange to do he says can you make it to
where mysterio never revealed my
identity this is very very different
than what we've heard doctor strange is
going to do in his spell and this is why
peter actually kind of as dr strange
says botches the spell because it's not
what he asked for but here's some
extremely new important dialogue dr
strange says that he stopped the spell
he specifically says in this tv spot
when i shut that spell down we started
getting visitors from the other
universes so here doctor strange doesn't
say that spider-man botched it he says
that he shut it down and this is most
likely due to spider-man during the
spell saying hey dude this isn't the
right spell that you're doing peter goes
into the sanctum looking for doctor
strange to erase what mysterio did not
to make everyone forget that he's
spider-man but to make it to where the
event where mysterio revealed his
identity didn't really happen because
these are two very very different things
and spider-man peter parker realizes
this as doctor strange is doing the
spell he doesn't want everyone to forget
that he's spider-man because that would
be very very problematic think about it
people like happy hogan pepper potts
wong falcon all of the other avengers
all of the people that participated in
avengers in game and of course the
people closest to him mj aunt may ned
none of them would know that he is
spider-man and that would essentially
erase all of those moments peter would
remember but nobody else would so peter
would remember but that's it and that
means that he wouldn't have help from
anybody which may actually be somewhat
of the point of spider-man no way home
that's something fans have been wanting
to see for a while peter on his own but
it does seem very clear that people
still do know that peter parker is
spider-man mj and ned are with him it
looks like throughout the entire movie
so this makes me believe one of two
things and one thing is i think some of
these tv spots are definitely edited to
make us believe certain things whether
that's the ordering of some words the
phrasing or whether that's simply
putting things in here that aren't
exactly going to be in the real movie
and we have now officially seen that
with this tv spot dr strange says two
different lines one when you botch that
spell but now in this tv spot he says he
shut it down so it looks like one of
these two lines is fake and marvel put
it in the trailer to throw us off again
marvel kind of does that for every
trailer that they have now and you can't
be mad at them for that they do it so
things remain a surprise to us and we've
already seen proof that they are doing
this remember lizard the invisible ghost
kicking him in the face which we know is
actually andrew garfield or tobey
maguire and get this there's a press
screening today and according to some
insiders like big screen leaks they're
only going to be shown the first 45
minutes of the film now of course the
reason that everybody is saying they're
only going to get shown the first 45
minutes is because sony doesn't want
them to see the other spiderman they
don't want them to see them on screen
and go spoil it for everybody else and
we all pretty much know but let's face
it there is that part in everybody
that's like until i see it until
somebody tells me that they've actually
seen it and the movie's been released
it's not 100 it's 99.99999
but not 100. and sony is really trying
to keep that a secret until you actually
see it on screen which i can't
appreciate but now the real question is
what exactly is going to happen in
spiderman no way home and luckily we
don't have that much longer to wait just
a couple of weeks now and i know
everybody's excited so let me know how
excited you are in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
let me know what you think about it of
course for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you